A theatre-owning koala, a timid elephant,
an overworked pig, a soulful gorilla, a punk-rock
porcupine, and an egotistical mouse are just
some of the characters you'll meet in the
animated musical movie, Sing.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
And in this video, I'm going to be revealing
behind-the-scenes secrets and facts about
the movie Sing including some cool easter
eggs.
Just before I start, I've got a giveaway for
some awesome Sing merchandise.
All you need to do for a chance to win is
subscribe and leave a comment on this video
about your favourite song, character or easter
egg from the movie.
For details about the prizes and bonus ways
to enter the giveaway, check out the Gleam
link in the video description below.
And if you've not seen the movie, just to
let you know there are spoilers ahead.
Ok, now, let's take a look at 17 fun facts
and easter eggs in the movie Sing.
For the soulful-singing gorilla Johnny, the
filmmakers channelled Michael J Fox's Marty
McFly from Back to the Future.
But that's just the start of Sing's hat-tips
to the iconic mid-80s movie.
Remember when the theatre's electricity suddenly
shuts down?
Well, Buster tries to get the power back on
by climbing out onto the theatre's façade
while pulling an electric cable from his building
and trying to connect it to a cable from the
building next door.
But like Doc, at the end of Back to the Future,
Buster's cable doesn't quite reach, and needs
an extra tug.
Oh, and did you notice the hands of the clock
outside Buster's theatre are on 10 and 12,
a shout-out to the scene in Back to the Future?
And in Sing's finale, when the punk-rocking
porcupine Ash performs 'Set It All Free',
she finishes with a final flourish on her
guitar as she knee-slides across the stage,
then she opens her eyes to find the audience
in stunned silence, which is a nod to Marty
McFly's guitar-heavy, knee-sliding performance
of Johnny B Good in Back to the Future.
The inspiration behind Sing and its characters
comes from a variety of places, including
Alan Parker's 1991 hit musical The Commitments.
And for the character of Gunter, a sparkly-spandex-wearing
pig whose dance performances are super-high
on energy, the filmmakers took cues from Brad
Pitt's personal trainer character in the Coen
Brother's comedy Burn After Reading.
As for Rosita, an overburdened mother to 25
piglets, Sing's writer-director Garth Jennings
based her on his own wife, who left her job
as a fashion designer to raise their four
children and, like Rosita, faced self-doubt
when she decided to return to her former profession.
Sing also includes a couple of easter eggs
to another of Illumination's animated movies,
The Secret Life of Pets, which is especially
nice because, if you remember, a poster for
Sing appeared on the back of the bus in that
movie!
Ok, first up, when Sing's bank-robbing gorilla
gang turns up, they're wearing masks that
look just like the crazy bunny Snowball, who's
the leader of The Flushed Pets gang in The
Secret Life of Pets.
And in another hat-tip to that movie, there's
a crocodile called Derek in both films!
In Sing, Derek works at the casino frequented
by Mike, the tiny mouse with an enormous ego.
And in The Secret Life of Pets, Derick is
a member of the Flushed Pets gang.
During the five years it took to bring the
final film to life, Sing went through various
changes and there were a number of rejected
concepts.
For example, when the filmmakers first came
up with the idea of the theatre-owning koala
Buster Moon, he was much more of a full-on
con artist than he is in the final movie.
However, as they developed the movie, they
realised that over-emphasising Buster's swindling
ways and bad manners was making him way too
unlikable.
So, they dialled down that aspect of his character.
Another character who went through a big change
during the making of the movie was a bullish
business mogul who, up until late in the film's
development, was going to be a big part of
the story.
But in the end, the filmmakers decided he
wasn't necessary to the plot, so his character
had a major downgrade and now you can only
see him in one scene, which is at the bank
where he gives a credit card to the Sinatra-singing
mouse Mike, who's voiced by Seth Macfarlane.
As well as directing Sing, Garth Jennings
also provides the voice of Buster's assistant,
the elderly lizard, Miss Crawly!
And keeping it in the family, Jenning's four
sons, Oscar, Leo, Caspar, and Asa all pop
up in the film, voicing piglets!
As does Asher Blinkoff, whose voice you'll
know best as Dracula's grandson Dennis in
the animated movie Hotel Transylvania 2.
By the way, did you spot that the speaking
voice of theatrical diva Nana Noodleman is
provided by Absolutely Fabulous star Jennifer
Saunders, who also voiced the Queen of England
in Illumination's Minions movie?
But when she's singing, Nana owes her voice
to Dreamgirls star Jennifer Hudson!
The Grand Budapest Hotel director Wes Anderson
also cameos as a giraffe called Daniel, who
Buster axes after the auditions because they
can't hear each other due to the difference
in their heights.
The voices of Despicable Me director Chris
Renaud and Scott Pilgrim vs the World director
Edgar Wright also appear briefly in Sing.
Sing is absolutely jam-packed with music,
with over 65 songs, covering everything from
Lady Gaga and John Legend to Frank Sinatra
and The Beatles.
However, one particular track, Elton John's
I'm Still Standing, proved especially tough
to get permission to use, taking six months
to get the go-ahead as, at the time, Elton
John's company Rocket Pictures was thinking
of using it for their own animated movie,
the Gnomeo & Juliet sequel, Sherlock Gnomes.
The final thing that sealed the deal in Sing's
favour was director Garth Jennings meeting
David Furnish, Elton John's husband and co-chief
at Rocket Pictures, and showing him the scene
where Taron Egerton's character Johnny belts
out the song in the movie.
Speaking of Taron Egerton, although Sing is
his first full-on musical experience on the
big screen, Egerton grew up singing and touring
in school choirs and, while he was training
at London's prestigious Royal Academy of Dramatic
Art, he won the Stephen Sondheim Society 'Student
Performer of the Year' award for his rendition
of two musical numbers including 'Giants in
the Sky' from Sondheim's Into The Woods.
However, as Sing's director had never heard
Egerton's vocals before, the Kingsman: Secret
Service star auditioned for the part of Johnny
by performing one of his favourite songs,
Otis Redding's These Arms of Mine.
By the way, if you were wondering about those
five brightly-dressed red pandas who pop up
singing and dancing several times during the
movie, they're a shout-out to the music of
the Japanese pop and fashion phenomenon that
is Kyary Pamyu Pamyu.
Now, who's your favourite character in Sing?
And what songs would you like to see in a
Sing sequel?
Tell me in the comments below!
Don't forget to subscribe and comment for
your chance to win some cool Sing merchandise!
For more details and bonus ways to enter the
giveaway, check out the Gleam link in the
video description below.
You can watch more videos like this by clicking
or tapping here, and remember to turn on your
notifications to make sure you get all my
new videos as soon as they're ready!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!